mcDonald's we talk a lot about
McDonald's and they do a lot of weird
stuff pink slime no they don't have pink
slime their new commercials that are
like add we're pretty awful so talk to
this board and it'll tell you how not
awful we are and all kinds of weird
stuff even the chicken it's alright
anyway
the CEO of McDonald's Don Thompson
recently spoke at an event at a venture
capitalist firm and he was asked what
they were doing to make children
healthier and he said that they actually
tried to take broccoli and make it taste
like bubblegum it did not work that's
right
to quote him it wasn't all that yeah
bubblegum flavored broccoli knocked all
that so they didn't do it now I know
it's easy to pile on McDonald's and we
do it here often but should we give them
a little credit for trying to make
broccoli tastier okay then okay first of
all the one little teeny tiny bit of
slack I'll give them is I don't know
when you guys were sick when you were
little did you ever get that really
opaque disgusting textured but delicious
bubblegum flavored medicine of course
okay so up in the eighties okay okay so
that like you know when you put throw
the bubblegum flavor on some stuff it
makes it better
however shame on you McDonald's
everybody has to eat their vegetables
and they're supposed to taste like
vegetables stop being an [ __ ] hey see
your other food just week broccoli
tastes like your other food don't make
it taste like something you're not
supposed to swallow bravo brett erlich
because yes right why can't they just
make it taste like the other [ __ ] that
everyone's addicted to already it's so
good in a way you're like it okay
vegetables they taste like stuff you're
supposed to chew and spit out so like
only swallow the [ __ ] we make otherwise
why just broccoli get such a bad rap now
I understand when I was six did not like
the broccoli my mom wanted me to eat
broccoli I remember it sitting there on
the table you're not gonna leave this
table that I love broccoli now there's
anyways little garlic oil there's so
many good things you do white well why
does broccoli get the bad rap and
Brussels sprouts they're great oh there
raise but that's an adult I didn't eat
them till about two years ago then you
got a cover and butter bacon those
cruciferous vegetables it's a texture
thing the texture is awful it raw yeah
am I really right well nobody was wrong
luckily but I guess lather it and ranch
dressing everybody know yeah at that
point you're not making it healthy
anymore but I get it what you're saying
like when I was a kid I was like I want
chicken with nothing on it yeah and if
you can make edible air that's it but
like that's that's what it comes out a
little cheese you can sprinkle that on
yeah we'll allow it so what are the more
dangerous thing have been here if they
had actually made this work if they had
had bubblegum flavored broccoli and kids
would have been eating that wouldn't
that have done actually more long-term
damage to people eating the right foods
because then you'd grow up thinking that
your broccoli has to taste like
bubblegum problem it would have been
more have more long-term damage because
God knows what they injected into the
broccoli to make it taste like bubblegum
I don't do kids would go into kidney
failure at eight years old can you
believe that that's someone's job you
know professor Frank can you make this
broccoli tastes like bubblegum yes for
sure yeah we can do anything no we can
make broccoli tastes like bubblegum we
can do anything I know really all right
final thought on this are we ever gonna
get food right in this country every
week now I've been doing something on
food and our food sources and all the
awful [ __ ] we're putting on stuff and
Monsanto and all that stuff
are we ever gonna get it right or are we
just gonna be in an endless high
fructose corn syrup lifestyle forever
I'd like to say we can get it right but
we're talking also about what you
brought up earlier the explosion of
population like how are we going to have
a system that puts out food to handle
all these people well then when right
now it's like if I want to eat right
it's gonna cost me a [ __ ] ton of money
to go down to to go down to hole
foods it's like twice as much when I
shop there so I don't know what the
solution is and the if I want to grow it
at my house that takes a certain amount
of affluence the people who are trying
to break it break through into like a
higher level of society it's it's it's
hard not to just go get mcdonalds for
your family because growing it in your
house goddamn squirrel that is eating
all my mint all I have is mint and this
squirrel
he's literally and he's mocking me
because he also buries peanuts where the
mint was and it's like a mine card like
a big right so yeah exactly he's like
the water bandit from what the thing is
like I can show my options are I can
spray it with some sort of chemical and
then when I have my mojito I can now be
drinking chemicals which I don't want to
do which is why I was growing the mint
in the first place yeah or I can be I'm
under the constant threat of this
squirrel so you know you can't win mesh
or something some kind of measure
however what we great is if it's late
let my plate we would look like a
freaking jail yeah so sad if right now
that squirrels with all the squirrel
forensic I met the most amazing generous
human and so I try to pay a bag of
peanuts yeah but I know this is
one-sided because that mean he's
delicious yeah that is a good point I
like peanut so why don't I just eat his
peanut it's very sweet of him you didn't
have to bring you anything